and we all
lost
we almost
[Music]
American Idol winner just Sam reveals
she's singing in the New York City
Subways just three years after winning
the hit singing competition just Sam
congratulations Sam you did it you got
it
[Applause]
for him he did it
Samantha Diaz who used the stage name
Jess Samwell competing on the show
previously made a living as a Subway
singer before appearing on the virtual
season of idol in 2020 during the
pandemic
I want you to feel safe
Uncle Luke
Auntie Katie
operation thank you after wowing the
judges week after week
[Music]
the singer went on to win the whole
thing how did those performances in the
subway prepare you for this American
Idol stage I would go on to the train
and
I of course like I love to sing but
there were days where I did not want to
be there but I needed the money I I
wanted to be able to pay my bills for my
grandmother I wanted to be able to have
food every day and I wanted to be able
to buy myself nice things like my
friends
you know so like I would sing my butt
off girl I was working I was not playing
but now Sam says she is back to seeking
donations from Riders on the subway
thank you
thank you for listening
in a since deleted comment on Instagram
Sam says that she was super embarrassed
to be going back to singing on trains in
2021 adding that she didn't want people
to know that she legit needed the money
I was disappointed in myself for
allowing myself to fall so low after
winning Idol but Sam says she's learned
so much and has been able to share her
experiences with other artists
I can bring myself to swim when I
went up drowning in this series baby let
me
ET recently spoke to AI judge Lionel
Richie who said their hope is that the
top contestants leave the show with a
career the top five the top ten can make
their careers happen and so the platform
of American Idol is just to get you
exposed ladies and gentlemen I mean pick
anyone and go make a career out of it
but that wasn't the case for Sam who
signed a record deal with Hollywood
Records after her season but parted ways
with the label without ever releasing an
album and last year Sam hopped on her
insta story to reveal she had gone broke
while paying off her record label I'm
not even going to tell you guys the
amount of money that I had to pay after
leaving the label to claim songs that I
had already recorded but Sam added she's
recording all the time making music all
the time and doing what she has to do to
survive glorious
hey
powerful
but Jesus
Jesus speaks